we can speak now to labors Shadow
Northern Ireland secretary Peter Carl
thank you for being with us thanks um
before we get on to Northern Ireland I'm
Keen to get your sort of reaction I
guess to the mark Harper interview he
told me I know that you all I think your
chair of the uh a all part party
parliamentary group on Southern rail so
you may have a bit of a vested interest
in rail strikes
um Mark Carper told me that the train
operating companies have got permission
from him to make a new offer to rail
companies
um so I guess on the one hand that's
good because it shows potentially there
could be a breakthrough but do you think
that also perhaps supports the Union's
argument that it is the government that
effectively is pulling the strings here
well it always has been I mean if you
look at you mentioned the southern rail
I mean the GTR who runs Southern rail
and Thames link they are actually is a
contract not a franchise and that's now
the system which is most broadly right
across the country and it means that
they can't do anything without the
government saying so so government sets
the Affairs sets of time scales the
government sets the the stations that
each train has to stop at so the idea
that for the entire summer when all of
this unrest was fermenting between a
staff workers and unions and the
government when Grant chaps refused to
engage or even meet with unions it was a
real it was a really missed opportunity
he should have been round the table he
should have been engaging they should
the government should have used the
influence it has to try and broker some
of these deals so it's good that he's
starting to now but it is an
acknowledgment we've had a wasted year
on the strikes you have we've had months
of rail strikes and nurses are saying
that more nurses are going to be walking
out next month at teachers balloting for
Action to a public sector workers right
to be taking industrial action they have
the right to take industrial action and
it's completely understandable as to
whether why they are we have had the
biggest sharpest longest fall in
real-term wages amongst workers across
the public sector so we understand what
the challenges are and that was going
into Kobe it after covert placed
enormous stresses and strains on public
sector workers and now we've got the
cost of living crisis as well we can't
just look at this in terms of the
relationship between people workers at
their actual jobs workers back home
their rents are going through the roof
the energy price is going through the
roof food costs going through the roof
because our economy is being
fundamentally mismanaged and then they
have these challenges at work with the
pay which in real terms has been cut
over the last decade so the
mismanagement of the economy is driving
this so it's not surprising that it's
spreading from one public service to
another and damaging our economy from
top to bottom I mean I guess just put
the government sort of come back to that
they would say that above inflation or
inflation matching pay Rises end up
stoking inflation I'm sure you'll have a
view on that as well and but I'm just
Keen to find out what labor would do
because look if you look at the polls
you know you are in line to be the next
government
nurses for example looking for payrolls
around 10 is that reasonable well the
interesting thing is the the nurses went
into these negotiations asking for
inflation plus five percent and of
course we in the labor party were honest
the economy is in a mess because of the
way it's been managed particularly in
the last year with a mini budget which
blew a hole in it so we were very honest
at the outset and said that that was
unrealistic and labor would not be able
to deliver those sorts of things now the
nurses have already moved that down to I
think 10 as their negotiating stance
these are things that are coming out in
public these are things that should be
resolved by negotiating in private
between employers and the unions now
back to the question because I am I do
think it's really important you know you
you I can understand why you say look
this is all about the mismanagement of
the economy we totally get why public
sector work as a striking look at their
gas bills what would you do what what is
a fair pay rise well first of all look
what we did do during the 12 there were
13 years of the last Labor government
we are that same we are that same party
with a party that respects the public
finances with a party that gets the
economy growing firing on all cylinders
and we're a party which knows how to
manage the public services and deals
with pay and conditions so if we were
negotiating from now we would have open
negotiations between government and the
public sector workers via their unions
and with their unions and we would
include pay and conditions in those
negotiations because clearly that's what
the unions are asking for that's what
they need we know that the unions are
moving and willing to move you can see
how the nurses unions have moved quite
considerably from their starting point
the government has to move as well and
go in and actually be willing to have
negotiations Sophie we're talking about
statecraft here why is Northern Ireland
in such a mess because of a failure of
statecraft and neglect from the
government here why is it that think
that when the Prime Minister goes to
Scotland he comes back empty-handed in
an acrimony and positions widen they
don't heal because we have a government
that can't do statecraft 101 they can't
get the basics of running any of the
relationships that are essential to
running an economy with its Public
Services the economy more broadly and
its International relationships but also
here domestically across the United
Kingdom itself we need to have a
government that takes State craft
diligence and graph the basics of
running a government seriously and when
people look at kierstama and I hope his
top teams too they see those qualities
in Spades so I know what you think of
Rishi sunak in a statecraft I know what
you think about the last Labor
government but I'm still a bit unclear
about what you'd actually do when it
comes to public sector pay well I've
said we will negotiate we will engage in
negotiations on pay and conditions
Rachel Reeves as Chancellor would also
get the essentials to Basics right a
running economy we want to reform the
economy and get growth into it we've got
the plan to deliver growth through
reforming business rates which would
turbocharge small businesses and and
rejuvenate High streets right the way
through to a green Prosperity fund which
will recapitalize and convert our
economy to get it ready and equipped for
the challenges of Net Zero all of these
things the things that we would do with
the economy to get the basics right and
we would also engage fulsomely in those
negotiations with employers we've done
it before and the labor next Labor
government will do it again I've been
quite interesting to
look at Labor's policy on the NHS
Kirsten's giving quite a Punchy
interview too with the Sunday Telegraph
uh effectively you know saying that look
the NHS that we talk about it have been
the admiration for the world but
actually you know it's kind of Reform or
die
do you think we need to be a bit more
honest I guess in politics and
Westminster about the state of the NHS
but I think here in his article today in
the telegraph he's been quite starkly
honest it's not the Envy of the world in
fact the world's relationship with the
NHS at the moment is a difficult one
because we are now recruiting more
doctors from abroad than we are actually
producing through training back home
that means that you know that the
government have turned our NHS in in our
country into a parasite we're going
around scouring the world looking for
talent to bring back to our NHS because
we're failing to reduce these doctors
and nurses domestically now we have a
plan by canceling the non-dom status to
fund the doubling of training of doctors
nurses and midwives and it will be the
biggest growth in training in the
history of the NHS but we that That's
the basis of the plan to tackle the
workforce challenges we have we also
need to reform the pensions for doctors
we're working with the BMA on that so we
can make sure that people aren't forced
to take early retirement and we can get
people who have retired back into the
service I'm interested um you say that
we're acting a bit of a power parasite
and taking you know doctors and nurses
from other countries do you think that's
something
only dubious then with almost like going
to countries many who are poorer than
the UK and taking the doctors that
they've trained it's not the sign of a
healthy economy you know the the the the
the the economy of our NHS that we are
so dependent on taking Talent from the
rest of the world and we're incapable
Britain in the 2020s is incapable of
producing enough doctors for our own
needs domestically so what the labor
party will do is double the training of
doctors and nurses this government cut 3
000 training places from our
universities and our training facilities
in the last year at a time when we need
to double it so this is again the
mismanagement of our NHS and also a
failure to think long-term and
strategically about the future of the
NHS because if you're not training
enough doctors now then in five ten
years time we're not still not going to
tackle the problems that we have today
that's why we need to get a labor
government in there with a plan of fully
costed plan to get the doctors and
nurses and midwives into our NHS that we
need who are trained here in our country
and I want to talk to you you're at
Northern Ireland at hat on now there's
been lots of discussion about the
protocol I mean for years and they're
basically right and you obviously have
conversations with people on different
sides of the debate
is it your sense that we might be edging
closer to a resolution
well we're certainly hearing that
negotiations are going better than
before but we keep on hearing these
briefings we keep on we've had 18 months
of discussions about mood music rather
than content so we really just need to
see what is going to be delivered by
these negotiations rather than just
constant negotiations on the tone it
shows just how poor this whole process
has been that we've had a year and a
half of conversation about the tone of
conversations rather than the content of
the company and you're willing to back
the government effectively on this
you've so the government published it's
uh it's command paper with all of its
negotiating Styles 18 months ago the EU
did so 15 months ago and there's a big
overlap in the middle it's about data
sharing it's about the difference
between whether we have a fast track or
a Green Lane we've spent 18 months
negotiating over something which really
should be dealt with in a matter of
weeks not years it's extraordinary to me
that the previous generation led by Tony
Blair delivered peace in Northern
Ireland this lot can't get a prawn
sandwich across the Irish sea so we
really need to just get around the table
and negotiate because Northern Ireland
has suffered from neglect neglect from
this government here and the fact that
every time we have conversations
positions widen we need to bring people
together because Northern Ireland
suffers most it always does when things
go wrong in the in the United Kingdom
and all night and suffers most just
finally you're not only supported a
second my friend and you even move the
motion for it and it has a Commons in
2019 you said it you felt hurt and
groomed betrayed when it didn't get
enough support
has brexit made us poorer
actually the brexit deal at the Bryce
Johnson negotiated has made us poorer
and we need to address that you know
kirstan has been really clear about this
we need to build on that deal you know
for example the only brexit make us poor
do you think I think we could what we
could have done is just fully fully
explored our potential outside of the
single market and that's what the labor
party aspires to do I don't think we've
touched the sides as a country of what
is possible outside of the single Market
you know for example you've got Peter
Carl saying uh about the opportunities
outside the single Market well Sophie
when when things change in in poverty
when something fundamental happens in
politics you lose a big vote where we
have a general election and the country
decides to go in a different direction
the political landscape changes and I'm
a politician that respects that so the
political landscape has changed we're in
a new reality and I accept it and I
fully want to explore the potential that
we have as a country right now not as
one that we had 10 years ago I was very
emotionally engaged in in that debate I
fought very very hard I lost the country
chosen New Direction and we need to
fully explore our potential I don't
think we have even touched the sides of
what we've done because the government
is governing by ideology under Kia
stalma we're being pragmatic we want to
rebuild the relationships that we have
around the country we want to rebuild
our economy out of the rubble of 10
years of austerity followed by two years
of crises we want to make sure that we
can rebuild our Public Services you know
these are the challenges that we have
and we can only start once we have the
general election and get a prime
minister that actually cares about all
of these things in a non-ideological way
but in a way that actually has
enthusiasm for the future of the country
not the kind of Doom and Gloom and the
governing by rail that we have with the
Tories okay we are at time thanks very
much being on the program thank you for
today thanks